a week's worth of action packed into a
few hours mr. Johnson's first outing at
p.m. queues have you lost control
Prime Minister finally in the driving
seat but losing his grip on the wheel a
new PM who faces a forced brexit
extension he knows he needs an election
to have any hope of really leading up
shortly but if that surrender bill is
passed
he will allow the people of this country
to have their view on what he is
proposing to happen to hand over in
their name with an election on October
that the thief Mr Speaker trying to goad
mr. Coburn into granting him one I know
he's worried about free trade deals with
America but there's only one chlorinated
chicken that I can see in this house
[Applause]
[Music]
that he will the people decide let the
people decide on what he is doing to
this country's negotiating position by
having a general election on October the
15th mr. Corbyn saying it's the Prime
Minister who's running scared he's
desperate absolutely desperate to avoid
scrutiny all a bit schoolyard
but tweets aside mr. Johnson with
nowhere to hide in this chamber we have
seized back control from a prime
minister who is behaving like a dictator
more than a Democrat
mr. speaker I'm a Democrat because I not
only want to respect the will of the
people in the respect of the referendum
but I also I also want to have an
election or I'm also willing to have an
election if they're if the right
honourable gentleman opposites terrible
bill goes through no slow down in the
Commons as MPs moved on to debate in a
block or mr. Johnson's No Deal brexit
the stage set for another round of the
Tories bloody civil war on Europe this
banished former Chancellor defiant there
is no mandate for a No Deal brexit and a
No Deal brexit will be a catastrophe for
the United Kingdom mr. Johnson's
supporters defiant to and this is a
squalid little bill to the front of
Parliament and to democracy and to the
people and I despair at the defeatism of
so many of my colleagues that I hope
that we will fight back and win in a
general election which I cannot wait the
government defeated they moved straight
there next damned bit to force an early
election it is completely impossible for
government to function if the House of
Commons refuses to pass anything that
the government proposed
and in my view and the view of this
government there must now be an election
on Tuesday the 15th of October you can
have it but with strict conditions let
this bill pass and gain Royal Assent
then we will back an election so we do
not crash out with a No Deal exit from
the European Union
yet another defeat mr. Johnson's lost
every Commons wait as Prime Minister
election does that mean then it's all
off the answer is no it's still a
question of when not if Labour divided
on whether to call an election in the
coming days once the No Deal law is
passed or whether to wait until November
but there's a good chance that mr.
Corbyn will go earlier than that he
believes he can beat Boris Johnson in a
general election and stop anodal brexit
at the polls this Prime Minister won the
2016 referendum he thinks he can win
again with the help of those brexit
votes if it backfires he'll go down in
history as the PM who served the
shortest ever term a huge gamble but the
only option he's got